on a toujours le pire depuis les
intuitions de monsieur legault on n'a
jamais de chiffres combien de gens ont
pas eu la qu'ovide parce qu'ils ont
imposé un couvre-feu pendant le temps
des fêtes combien de gens n'ont pas la
coved aujourd'hui pas ce qui est en
train de [ __ ] les restaurants en
faillite en les fermant pour une
quatrième fois
combien de gens ont pas la coved au
québec parce qu'on a fermé les cinémas
pendant les semaines du plus payant de
l'année si les mesures sanitaires et s
efficace que son aura de meilleurs
bilans pollués
bref entendu le chef du parti
conservateur du québec éric duhaime
aujourd'hui
demande donc la levée de toutes les
mesures sanitaires ces puits sont en
hausse selon un sondage léger publié ce
matin il a gagné quelques points 6
points depuis décembre
c'est mon invité ce soir éric duhaime
bonsoir mille de 24,60 bonsoir madame
sous et cette demande de lever les
restrictions les mesures sanitaires est
ce que ces responsables à ce moment ci
au moment où le système de santé crawl
écoutez le problème de plus en plus on
le voit le problème majeur au québec
c'est notre système de santé beaucoup
plus que le virus un juge ce que je
réclame aujourd'hui le sait exactement
ce que le royaume uni vient d'annoncer
un peu plus tôt dans la journée où ils
vont lever justement les mesures
sanitaires ou le leu leu le mas ne soit
plus obligatoire vous le passez par
vaccinale votre spa wright où les gens
vont pouvoir reprendre une vie normale
ou télétravail n'est plus encouragés
donc on obtient paquet des temps au sud
de nos frontières on n'a pas besoin d'en
parler très longtemps on au juste à
regarder les matchs de nfl ce week-end
pour voir des 66 88 personnes entassées
alors qu'ils ont un taux de vaccination
deux fois moindre que le nôtre on a 2 5
x 280 quelques personnes aux soins
intensifs même 300 qu'ils ont mais un
milliard de $ par part me parle par
semaine dans des systèmes de santé
madame tussauds et on n'est pas capable
de soigner 280 personnes de 300
personnes il ya aussi le problème c'est
le système de santé de toute évidence
vous évoqué l'exemple de voyous mené de
boris johnson qui fait cette annonce sur
la fin du mois parce que tu es en train
de sauver sa carrière politique parce
qu'on lui reproche d'avoir participé à
des rassemblements illégaux
ce que vous ne dites pas par ailleurs
dans votre réponse en disant cela c'est
que c'est le pays le plus endeuillé a eu
une gestion chaotique de la de la
pandémie et que cette annonce
d'aujourd'hui s'accompagne d'une
campagne de vaccination massive
oui mais on est on est déjà l'endroit le
plus vaccinée madame tussauds on est les
québécois ont été très dociles et
obéissants on y ceux qui se sont le plus
fait vacciner et malgré cela le
gouvernement continue à nous imposer les
mesures les plus liberticides
c'est ici où on respecte le moins les
droits individuels des droits de la
personne c'est ici où la démocratie est
en pause depuis deux ans et on voit
qu'un et 47 aiguë dans la population je
ne sais pas si vous le sentez mais moi
je le sens on écarte ses 1000 nouveaux
membres au parti conservateur
il commence à y avoir une grogne et
monsieur le goût vous l'avez par les lez
lille ces chiffres dans les sondages
commencent à descendre il doit voir un
jour qu'ils soient les coûts de la
population le reste amateur qui menacent
même d'ouvrir leurs portes dans les
prochains jours il également sur toute
la cohésion sociale à revenir sur les
mesures sanitaires avant de parler des
radios rampe avons nous oublié là dedans
les mesures center c'est le masque la
distanciation social se laver les mains
donc on a ajouté aussi la distanciation
mais aussi le moins de contacts
possibles dans cet esprit là qu'on veut
freiner l'eau micron qui est extrêmement
transmissibles donc cessé mais il
remettait en question maintenant il y en
a d'autres qui n'avaient pas fait leur
part maximale
non je vous lis besoin du helmand où ils
voyagent gratuitement c'est le masque le
masque d'abord ce que j'ai dit ce que
j'ai dit aujourd'hui je vais vous le
répéter c'est qu'il faut y aller
graduellement évidemment mais les
premières mesures quant à moi qui
doivent partir c'est de permettre aux
gens de recommencer à socialiser je
pense que c'est important que les gens
puissent recevoir leur famille leurs
amis à super c'est important de réouvrir
les restaurants c'est important
d'éliminer le passeport vaccinale parce
que c'est un outil discriminatoire et on
a aucune évidence scientifique que salle
une quelconque un quelconque impact si
vous sur quel sens et puis oui mais je
m'appuie sur la science que ça
fonctionne elle passe par vaccinale
monsieur le gouray pour fermer tous les
endroits où il y avait que des gens qui
montraient leurs passeports vaccinale si
si le passeport vaccinale éliminait le
risque comprenez qu'on n'aurait pas
fermé les endroits où il ya juste du
monde qui rentrent avec un passeport
dans l'économie de davantage de parts de
possibilité d'imposer le passeport
vaccin je pense à la fédération des
chambres de commerce on veut juste un
mini quincaillerie qui ont fait le
contraire aujourd'hui soumis à des gens
la fédération des chambres de commerce
et d'autres qui demandent le passeport
vaccinale pour protéger oui alors je
reviens avec ma mère à mon point de
départ sur quelle science vous appuyez
vous pour dire que les mesures
sanitaires ne sont pas efficaces puisque
je vous donne l'exemple du match on vous
a vu hier avec anne casabonne bras
dessus bras dessous parce qu'avant il
n'y a pas un breton bressou pas de
masque on peut voir la photo même quel
message qu'envoie c'est qu'on peut et
qu'on peut éviter la distanciation qu'on
peut ne pas porter le masque jeunesse où
vous me demandez vous me demander c'est
quoi la science derrière ce mois je vais
vous de répondre par une question c'est
que la science derrière non mais laissez
moi juste du banc c'est quoi la science
derrière les employés de la saq et de la
escudé c'est qu'ils ont acquis qui ont
qui ont eu tout où on oblige de le le
passeport vaccinale depuis 48 heures
alors que ses employés le second dit
vous avez droit de travailler mais si
vous êtes vous n'êtes pas vacciné mais
vous n'avez pas le droit d'acheter une
bouteille de vin on peut parler des
clients mais rentrez pas acheter une
bouteille de vin que vous avez pas droit
il ya des incohérences qui le les
québécois en ont soupé de ces
incohérences le madame je pense que de
plus en plus de gens vous et vos
téléspectateurs qui comprennent ça je
vais vous soumettre le sondage de ce
matin des légers sûr parce que vous
étiez un grand mais contre oui peut-être
mécontentement vous semblez canaliser ce
mécontentement là notamment sur les
mesures c'est à moi je fais la
différence entre les mesures sanitaires
publics s'en vont y venir au vaccin pour
passer par action voyez vous ce matin là
les l'étau d'abord monsieur legault est
très populaire le taux de satisfaction
est à 60%
67% appuie la mesure pour la ssq dci la
saq pour la vaccination obligatoire
permet pas encore 65% qu'une taxe santé
61% le couvre-feu même là dessus
plusieurs boucles conseil drake la
science on pourrait d'abord avec 7 49%
l'idée c'est de ces d'empêcher les
contacts donc ce que vous dites c'est
faux quand vous dites que c'est
généralisé puis qu'une dictature la
majorité le laissant les sondages
l'homme en tant qu un appui madame
madame dessous vous ajoutiez aussi pour
garder vous savez comme moi quand on
analyse les sondages en politique vous
regardez d'abord et avant tout les
tendances ce qu'on marque d'une
dégringolade de plus en plus prononcée
de monsieur legault quatre meilleurs
savoir non 4% sur les intentions de vote
mais son sens satisfaction de baisser de
15% madame qui est encore le meilleur
il est rendu miami a été près le
meilleur pendant deux ans mais derrière
la colombie britannique depuis quelques
semaines mais ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que tout ça est en train de mener
là on arrive à une écoeurantite aigüe
les québécois l on est très bon à ce
même en est on sait car il a je pense
qu'on est rendu au point de bascule moi
je connais beaucoup de gens qui ont
beaucoup apprécié le 31 décembre dernier
ce faire et que rice leur cible est
super rapide qu'on avait un couvre-feu
j'ai vu beaucoup j'ai eu beaucoup de
monde qui étaient furieux après monsieur
le gonfle beaucoup plus de gens
satisfaits alors j'ai lu que vous aviez
déclaré que dans le fond au québec on
abolit enfants dans le plus de fans au
québec c'était comme si c'était au
centre de votre programme politique
est-ce que c'est descend comme programme
politique
fort au québec madame
madame sont en tout respect le lit jean
lou lyon il ya des choses qui sont
essentiels dans la vie le gouvernement
que des fonctionnaires
il y avait des gens qui pour qu'ils leur
emploi est essentiel pour d'autres gens
qui sont pas essentiels ils sont faisait
que leur job il s'est pas essentiel ils
sont faites et sa part des politiques
qui ont jamais perdu une scène qui ont
eu un peu un laissez-passer pour pau est
obligé de respecter le couvre-feu et qui
en plus n'ont pas non plus à qui on ne
demande même pas le passeport pour
entrer à l'assemblée nationale alors que
c'est les seuls c'est facile de dire aux
gens faites quelque chose puis nous on
est au dessus des lois puis on sait ce
qu'on dit pas ce qu'on fait à un moment
donné le il faut que les élus
comprennent au québec qu'il ya un
mouvement qui est en train de naître et
c'est pas ça la division de la société
québécoise adam shaw sais pas si c'est
pas quelque chose de positif non parce
qu'on peut viser
que vous nourrissez pas pourquoi ne
mettez vous pas autant d'énergie à don a
plaidé pour la vaccination qui pour la
planète entière c'est la solution est un
bout de chemin à faire parce que le nom
on était jolie du maxxi n'est l'ennemi
quand j'arrive public les non-vaccinés
occupe encore 50% des idées aux soins
intensifs et ils sont à risque pour eux
m sont à risque pour les autres alors
pourquoi ne pas déployer autant
d'énergie à plaider pour envoyer des
gens se faire vacciner que de demander
seulement là madame durand terme est un
démocrate
pour moi les droits incluent les droits
fondamentaux les droits civiques c'est
fondamental moi j'ai jamais pensé vivre
dans un état où depuis deux ans on ne me
la démocratie sur pause je pensais
jamais vivre dans un état où on
refuserait à des gens d'entrer dans des
endroits des commerces c'est à chaque
fois dans l'histoire de l'humanité le
canton à discriminer de cette façon là
madame sous vous le savez mieux que moi
ça c'est jamais bien fini à la
discrimination systémique on est
antienne d'instituer la division
alimenté par un chef d'état c'est
inacceptable vous ne parlez comme son
état en chine on va faire entendre deux
experts qui ont parlé sont aux anges
depuis deux jours je vous demander de
réagir je vous demander de me révéler
qu'ils sont vos conseillers
scientifiques on écoute docteur douanes
d'acteurs prendre pour ceux qui pensent
que c'est au micron c'est juste un rhume
c'est faux il faut vraiment s'enlever
cette vidéo micron peut causer une
maladie aussi grave que delta et ça va
être particulièrement vrai chez les non
vaccinés je pense que tout le monde peut
faire savoir quand vous faites vacciner
comme unité vos contacts vous diminuer
le poids qui est exercée sur le réseau
est directement vous sauver des vies
rien moins que ça
et vous vous affichez avec une candidate
qui est anti vaccins tenu des propos que
je répèterai pas à long terme les pentes
ipex le modèle adictel cochonneries qui
est ce qu elle l était une épine pas
c'est une satire inspiré d'un monologue
qui l'avait fait dans un film de pierre
falardeau à titre de comédienne est-ce
que vous lui avez demandé d'effacer ces
sites oui tous ses épaules on ne
retrouve pas ce qu'on a fait comme elle
expliqué lors de la conférence de presse
c'est que ennemis se repose pendant
quelques jours ces réseaux sociaux parce
que on écrit une nouvelle page
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on est rendu à 17
ou 18 mille personnes que ceux qui l'ont
joint parce qu'on voulait canaliser le
toutes les personnes ne conservatrice
qui joignait et qui veulent s intéresse
à madame casabonne d'aller sur le
nouveau réseau social qui est le créer
est ce qu'elle est vaccinée
écoutez vous savez comme moi vous savez
très bien qu'elle ait choisi de ne pas
répondre à cette question là et moi je
l'appuie dans cette décision le mois
j'ai moi j'ai parlé de ce mois j'ai dit
mon statut vaccinal comme vous savez
mais je respecte la liberté de choix et
pour moi c'est de l'information
confidentielle vous avez vu ce qui s'est
passé à guillaume lemay thivierge a il
poursuit même à midi au parce que ils
ont révélé son statut vaccinal pour 1.8
millions de dollars on voit le si des
tribunaux le mot je considère que c'est
une information confidentielle est ce
que vous faites le plein d des antilles
dax dans votre camp des complices sur
la question je la reprends j'ai deux
questions en même temps mais ça se
rejoint pourquoi vous serez d'époque
pour une vaccination encore la troisième
dose pour aller plus loin pour qu'on
atteigne claude et aux six équipes
trois questions vous avez trois
questions vous parlez des des complexes
qu'on est un rassemblement de
complotisme d'anti vaccin juste vous
dire que dans la région de québec où je
me trouve présentement c'est une des
régions les plus vaccinée de toute la
province actuellement est ici le parti
conservateur du québec compte sur
l'appui de 22 % de l'électorat alors que
6 % non vaccinés à montréal qui est la
région la moins vacciner au québec il ya
des quartiers où il ya même 40% des gens
qui sont pas adéquatement vacciner on
est à 2 % dans les intentions de vote
donc faut faire attention aux amalgames
ce serait dangereux dans ce dance
possible parce que ya pas de corrélation
il ya même plus que celui trois quarts
de nos de nos sympathisants qui sont
doublement vacciner pour ce qui est de
la troisième dose madame tussauds
moi je suis contre le pasp avec sauna la
3do je suis contre le fait qu'on ajoute
une troisième dose il a raison si je mon
propre cas moi j'ai attrapé l'aco vite
dans le temps des fêtes est mon médecin
mon propre médecin me dit d'attendre
trois mois avant de me faire vacciner
parce que les anticorps actuels sont
supérieurs aux vaccins et jeu ni même la
docteure quoi j'étais sur vos ongles la
semaine dernière pour dire qu' aucun
avantage et aucun bénéfice et que
c'était inutile de le faire mais le
gouvernement pousse parce qu'il veut
rentrer son passeport vaccinale avant
trois mois et pour des raisons
politiques on est en train d'aller
contre que les scientifiques nous
recommande trouve ça normal il sait ce
que ça fait de moi quelqu'un qui est
artistique et anti vaccin parce que
j'aime l'écouter la science que la
politique parce que j'aime mieux qu'eux
mais un médecin qu'un politicien
l'incitation des questions scientifiques
alors percuté mais consiste scientifique
que je voulais révèlerai pas parce que
je vais leur parler avant s'ils veulent
parler mais ça vaut pas plaisir de
demander leur demander de vous appuyez
sur l'urgence mais parce que je m'étais
de la transparence de la part du
gouvernement etc
je commencerai pas donner leurs noms sur
les ondes avant de leur avoir parlé
comprenez avec les propos qu'elle a
tenus c'est une candidate crédible
je peux vous dire madame souk
aujourd'hui l'oeil de certains
commentateurs certains adversaires
politiques qui trouvent qu'elle n'est
pas crédible mais s'il avait pu il
aurait tous il aurait tous pris dans
leur parti politique parce qu'ibm est
adorée de tous et bien je peux vous etc
ainsi que je fais est approché et je
peux vous dire que c'est une c'est une
candidature qui pour nous est important
puis l'élection dans magic thooris une
élection très importante avec la
première fois que les gens vont pouvoir
se prononcer sur la gestion de crise de
françois legault il parti conservateur
est présent pierre casabonne vos
travaillé très fort et ici comme un
intérêt collectif monsieur doit on a
parlé de solidarité que le vaccin est
important pour sortir de cette pandémie
là on peut demander à madame casabonne
de renoncer à
au fait qu'elle dit que ce soit privé
l'histoire de vaccins qu'elle plaide
elle aussi en faveur du vaccin
écoutez madame casabonne a le droit le
au québec nous on a toujours eu la
liberté de pouvoir oui ou non s'injecter
quelque chose dans notre corps et même
là là là bond il faut que ça soit libre
et éclairé remy et le présentement l'on
n'ait pas lieu on est on est si le
gouvernement va aller au bout de ses
actions sont sa logique commencé c'est
que point plan n'y a pas omis la
vaccination obligatoire vous croyez
de respecter le choix des gens je me
raccroche pas mais je lui dis que
mandela faut respecter si on respecte la
liberté des gens qu'on impose beau la
vaccination obligatoire mais respectons
là jusqu'au bout donc ya pas de
contradiction en terminant va vous citez
dany turcotte que mise sur les réseaux
sociaux hier une déclaration de vous de
2010 où vous l'avez vu c'est certain les
artistes peuvent être dangereux quand
ils se prennent pour des scientifiques
qui influencent l'opinion publique
madame souches peuvent sortir des
entrevues que j'avais fait dans le passé
qu'il pouvait être
très fiers de notre vue confier d'avoir
merci monsieur jam on espère à d'autres
réponses éventuellement merci bonsoir à
trouvera tout revoir très bientôt
pouvoir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit